[Music]
our vegas golden knights back on the ice
at t-mobile arena tonight it might feel
like deja vu the knights facing off
against the coyotes again
after monday's thriller sports director
chris matthews
here with more on tonight's repeat
matchup chris ryan you tell me those
desert dogs are back in las vegas still
here
well it's a big game tonight for the
knights they've got to battle from
behind the last few nights
not tonight though vegas jumped on those
coyotes early vegas was looking forward
making emphasis on starting quickly in
the game and today they did that
shay theodore scores his first of the
season that's the first defensive goal
of the season it's one nothing vegas and
then another defensive goal
this time it's alex petrangelo and vegas
goes up two nothing
but they're rolling along tonight here's
mark stone with the game winner
he tips in the puck he's got points now
in all four games vegas adds two more
shea theodore scores his second of the
game alex tuck would also score tonight
vegas got terrific support in the net
for marc-andre fleury final 5-2
vegas may have played its best game of
the season so far
three of the four goals were by
defenseman
yeah um you know i was talking to petro
for the game and he's
we were both saying how it's kind of
weird that none of the d have pitched in
yet so
um you know it's convenient that tonight
was the night and
you know hopefully it continues four
games in there's always work to do but
uh i liked some of the things we fixed
from
from the prior game and you know some
guys got rewarded which
which was nice that certainly was nice
knights will now hit the road for the
first time this season they travel to
phoenix
yes again to meet the arizona team and
brian
i'm hearing there may be a bunch of
knights fans there in the building
because arizona
is allowing fans inside